are you going to continue making movies
or just uh be a housewife
it's really um
good woman and a great actor
that was a 25 year old Elizabeth Taylor
in a 1957 interview with Edward R Murrow
on the CBS News show Person to Person
during her six decade-long career the
Hollywood icon starred in nearly 60
movies among them National Velvet the
Epic Cleopatra and who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf she earned her second
Oscar for that one she was also of
course a tireless advocate in the fight
to cure HIV and AIDS even taking that
fight to Capitol Hill
the people on the front lines of this
fight need our help
urgently to save lives
we cannot let them down
author Kate Anderson Brower has written
Elizabeth Taylor the grit and glamor of
an icon it is the first authorized
biography of the Superstar it's based on
Diaries and letters along with
interviews with the people closest to
her in her life and we are happy to say
that Kate Anderson Brower and Elizabeth
Taylor's grandson Quinn tivy joined us
now Quinn is also an officer of the
Elizabeth Taylor AIDS Foundation good
morning to both of you good morning uh
Quinn I got questions for you but I want
to start with Kate I imagine that you
read a lot of other things about
Elizabeth Taylor and then got access to
the Diaries and the letters when you did
that and people had not seen those
before what did you learn
I I learned that she was so much more
complicated than the headlines suggested
at the time you know she was a
passionate Fierce woman she also had a
lot of vulnerability in her own life and
the letters I thought between her and
her husbands over the years especially
with Richard Burton it showed somebody
who was deeply in love wanting to fight
for love and um it it showed her own
um her own struggles the love letters
are really remarkable there's a
tear-stained uh letters and and just the
beauty of her relationships as we
remember all the rest yeah and she was
also a great writer I'm mean some of
these letters she wrote to people after
they passed away and one of the letters
I love she wrote to Michael Jackson
after he died and how painful that was
for her because they were very close and
then she wrote to Richard Burton where
she talks about how much she just wants
to hold him again I mean it's almost
like her own form of therapy yeah it was
also clear in the book that Mike Todd
was her true was certainly her true love
and she talked about that and and that's
where you come into Quinn because your
mom is Liza talk yeah thank you Mike
because Liza Todd is your mom but I like
in the book where you said okay she
never thought of herself as larger than
life she was always famous and I wonder
did you see her as Larger than Life
number one what did you call her I
called her grandma grandma was as simple
as grandma yeah did you see her as
larger and larger than life because
growing up to you she was grandma she
was Grandma of course
Grandma also meant huge parties and big
get-togethers she would bring us all
together for Thanksgiving for Easter for
whatever but her Easter parties were
much bigger than the parties I was
otherwise kind of Epic so I know you
write in the book that Quinn and your
brother Reese were like kittens going up
the steps to visit her and there's a
sweet story of you laying in bed
watching movies with her did you learn
something about her that you didn't know
in this process because the family had
to sign off on Kate doing this book yeah
um
in my relationship with her personally I
kept her celebrity in sort of a
different pocket and I just knew her as
this amazing woman and as this wonderful
and sweet and loving grandma
so in my job as a trustee in my job
working with her estate and my job now
helping with this book and getting to
read Kate's excellent work I've learned
so much more about her as an icon and
the things that I'm seeing are inspiring
me to you yeah yeah and the way that she
lived her life Kate you don't shy away
from getting into the so so-called Rock
Bottom experiences with Elizabeth Taylor
knowing that the family would be reading
it knowing that they had opened the
doors to you was it difficult to
confront the full truth of it all I was
pleasantly surprised that they were open
to talking about her struggles with
addiction I mean she was the first
person
um to to really talk about going to
Betty Ford uh she had obviously famous
struggles with her weight and she was
the punch line of a lot of jokes
throughout her life and I think that the
family was finally ready to to talk
about her
um her passion and the pain that she
lived with you know she was when at the
time she was 26 she had been twice
divorced and once widowed after Mike
Todd died so this is a woman who had
been through an incredible amount of
loss but she's also somebody who was the
first influencer she's somebody who was
bringing up issues in the 50s and 60s
like gun control and age her work on age
was legendary but but I like I like that
she apparently gave you advice about
love Quinn or about dating Mike Nichols
said three things about Elizabeth you
never saw it never saw tell a lie be
unkind be on time which family members
say is true what was the advice she gave
you about lover dad
yourself be yourself it has worked I am
happily married that's my camera love
you oh
boy Tybee we love love here got his
grandmother's eye I love love here we
love this book as well it's it's a
tremendous accomplishment uh so much
Kate Anderson Brower Quinn Tybee thank
you both very much Elizabeth Taylor the
grit and glamor of an icon is on sale
right now up next look at all that
matter this week we'll be right back